is like not tonight honey and deny him
sexual release
one second it's an issue yes please if i
was to repeat the same thing
i'm gonna put my feet up no oh yeah
there's a reason behind it there's a
reason yeah
if i said the same thing and i quoted a
hadith across many studies
and measures men have been shown to be
to have more frequent and more make sure
the mic is close
right and more intense sexual desires
than women as reflected spontaneous
in spontaneous thoughts about sex
frequency
frequent frequency and variety of sexual
fantasies
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
a traditional marriage and family is a
great risk for men in this day and age
if a man wants a child of his own i
would suggest that he go to either
mexico or thailand and have a surrogate
mother give birth to his own child
that way his child can never be taken
away by the mother
and he often pays thirty to forty
thousand dollars to have his own child
free do you see the extremes he's gone
through he's literally telling you to
travel to another country
and get a surrogate mother can you
imagine the extremes that
this is this is very worrying you know
what the show this show this guy is
if his kids have been taken away from
him that is always happening he's going
to extremely
like bro remember when we went to
california let me tell you something
yeah
but we went to california we're not
going to mention what state or what
happened but we went to california
brothels yes
i remember look you don't you just said
it i i know man and tell
tell them the story man bro if we're
talking about the the same story
it's when the when the guy his kids were
in custody went to the mother and he
couldn't see his kids and then what did
he do
yeah yeah he shoot him he shot the two
daughters and he shot himself yes yes he
shot the two daughters
obviously that's a condemnable action a
monstrous action but the point is
it drives men to insanity bro yes
when you play around with kids yes and
this is a serious issue and once again
it's documented very well in the red
pill
um documentation it's extremely and
people do this today man
people are trying to snatch kids away
from the father and this can mentally
disturb them to the point of
insanity it's it's um people don't
realize how big of an injustice
in her thirties and she will say things
like not tonight honey and deny him
sexual release
and possibly use that as a way to
control him
how many videos how many businesses
you've got once it's got like almost a
million almost a million views yeah
eleven thousand likes
one point four five thousand um dislikes
that's about nine percent
of dislikes of the full um count yeah
yeah
this is an issue bro one second it's an
issue yes please if i was to repeat
the same thing i'm going to put my feet
up now oh yeah there's a reason behind
it there's a reason yeah
if i said the same thing and i quoted
the hadith which the process
said that the angels cursed a woman who
when the the husband is asking for
intimacy she says no so first you can
see from the hadith
that it doesn't say go grab it by the
hair and say come here and i'm going to
wherever you too yeah
because it shows that she has a right to
say no and that's cursor absolutely
this is a fact that this guy is stating
and yes you know what in this city if it
looks like the man is actually sexually
uh blackmailing it's actually the
opposite way around she's saying no
and i i i don't want you that's
manipulation now we're not seeing this
is we're not saying there's certain
scenarios where a woman can't yeah no no
no no but
what's the point of a relationship
exactly what we're seeing is this
talking about a woman that is actually
using her
femininity against the man yes and
nobody talks about it so much so that
when you read the hadith you're reading
it with a
a oh this sounds oh my gosh towards a
woman hold on a second
why isn't this hadith scene i thought in
a second she is actually abusing him
so much so that the angels are cursing
her yeah no you know i think that
there's an assumption here which i think
second wave feminists once again
have tried to promulgate and it's the
assumption that both men and women are
the same sexually
but look at this i'm just going to i'm
going to say this yeah look open it
brother i'm going to give you one second
one second nonsense okay okay this this
is one study that was from roy
baumiesta i might be pronouncing their
wrong name wrong
and catholics yeah and another one
kathleen devos and the question is it
doesn't sound like muslims
no it's definitely not is there a gender
difference in strength of sex drive
yeah that's the name of the question
okay listen to the abstract the sex
drive refers to the
strength of sexual motivation across
many studies
and measures men have been shown to be
to have more frequent and
more make sure the mic is close right
and more intense sexual desires than
women as reflected spontaneous
in spontaneous thoughts about sex
frequency
frequency and variety of sexual
fantasies desired frequency of
intercourse desired number of partners
masturbation
and i know some people in this room know
a bit about that
i'm only joking lacking for various
sexual practices
willingness to forego sex initiating uh
versus refusing sex
making sacrifices for sex yeah no
comment
using the breath and other measures
listen to this listen to this
psychological um kind of peer-reviewed
study to write the following
in such generalized terms it's
incredible no contrary findings
indicating stronger sexual motivation
among women were found hence
that no contrary findings including
indicating
stronger sexual motivations among women
were found hence
listen hence we conclude that the male
sex drive is stronger than the female
sex drive
the gender difference in sex drive
should not be generalized to other
constructs such as sexual orgasmic
or orgasmic capacity enjoyment of sex or
extr
extrinsically motivating something
you've never experienced in your life
look here's the point let me tell you
something right the assumption once
again of identicality
falls flat on his face like this mic
right any
serious scientist or psychologist or
social scientist
will know that all studies really and
this is
indicated in the peer-reviewed
literature indicate a difference so if
there's a difference
the quran makes this clear it says yeah
the human being has been created weak
allah describes this and this the
festival exegetes
he they they say this is referring to
sexual weakness this is a weakness
for men it's a yeah
it's much more exacerbated for men
because that once again go into farron's
definition lack of power you know the
fact that we don't have as much
control over sexual desires as women do
should be
something which once again the
complementary system
yes should mean that the woman helps us
a little bit with this because quite
frankly there is an expectation there is
and he's right and he says this in other
places
there is a societal expectation for men
to
protect women in other scenarios men if
there was some kind of he was talking
about in another video that i watched of
his
you know the plane uh dropped or
something like that in the sea and women
and children were
kind of told to exit first and the women
and children rule applies over and over
again women and children are
prioritizing safety matters
the truth of the matter is if society
should operate in those ways and we
don't deny that that should be the case
by the way
we're happy with that well we haven't
got an issue with it really yeah
but if such weaknesses of women
quite frankly are to be kind of dealt
with by the strengths of men
then at least let the opposite happen
let the weaknesses of man
be hel will help us no no no no no no no
no no no no help
biologically emotionally intellectually
you name it whatever you want to name it
okay this shows you that this is a peer
review this is this is studies showing
this
yeah if a man has a higher sex drive or
whatever it is it shows that we need a
unique attention in that area
this person is not me let me make it
clear this doesn't mean
i'm going to force my wife no we're not
talking about we're not talking about
we shouldn't even we shouldn't even we
shouldn't even understand what we're
saying
sadly we have to say but we have to yeah
the thing is this
if in a certain situation where there's
a threat to my me and my
wife walking down the road yes and i
have to perform i'm not going to say
go i have to because because of her
strength
it's biological because of my stress
if that is the case at that given moment
that i have to perform in that very
moment to that threat yeah
it's as good as saying so you're a
full-time security guard okay yes but so
that means in a certain area
yeah i'm paying that yeah so and i could
die i can die on the on the course yeah
so the thing is if it comes to intimacy
and if a husband is asking his wife to
come
have intimacy and she's saying no no
problem you have the right to say no
but what you're doing is now you're
hypocrite you're an absolute
walking talking hypocrite yeah that's it
because you're you're happy
you're happy to take protection of men
when weaknesses of women are
uh are shown yeah look i i i totally
agree with this point and i think this
is sadly like you've said something
which is
do you know what this shows among all
above all things yes
the fact that he said this and so many
people agreed with him on this and
they're not muslims right yeah
so this is not muslim specific issue
number one okay you can't attribute this
this behavior to islam this is a
non-muslim website a
youtube page number one number two okay
which i think is very important as well
yeah is that this shows how much
resentment
there is among men for women who do this
to them now you can see you can feel the
although he's trying to be kind of
monotone
but you can kind of hear through his
content the emotion in his
in in what he's trying to say he's been
probably hurt
many of the people that are going on his
website youtube page have been hurt and
that is because
let me tell you the reason why is
because the system has been unjust
towards men
and and also has been unjust towards
women
and this system is unjust towards men
and women
the answer is reciprocity the answer is
complementarity
and the answer is islam until next time
that was a good video man i don't know
appeals yeah
sorry about this bro